hello everyone and welcome back to the
third day of the second game of the
ancients us rapid knockouts it's young
duda versus magnus carlsen and like
yesterday magnus started with a win then
the second game ended in a draw and now
we're gonna see what happens in the
third game uh it's quite an enjoyable
one it features two really awesome
positive video moments so let's dive
straight into it to do that with the
white pieces opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening uh knight to f6 by
magnus knight to c3 and now e5 so just
the two normal two knights variation of
the english and now g3 going for the
carlos bremen system uh we have bishop
to b4 thus missile variation against
this and not knight to f3 uh we have e4
challenging this knight and now knight
the d4 we have knight to c6 uh
challenging white's knight here and now
knight back to c2 uh challenging the
bishop here we have bishop captures and
c3d captures on c3 kind of doubling uh
white spawns here
but at some point you will bring this
knight over to d5 so it should not be a
problem uh we have h6 by magnus and now
there is a game where knight the e3 was
played but here we have bishop to g2 by
duda and it is now already as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
uh magnus continues with d6 he wants to
develop his light square bishop we have
h3 and now b6 the bishop will be
developed on this diagonal by fiance we
have knight to e3 uh and now comes
bishop to b7 and now as we mentioned the
knight is coming to d5 so knight to d5
if black should ever capture the knight
white will just nicely undouble his pawn
so here we have knight to e5 by magnus
and now bishop to f4 do the continuous
development we have castles by magnus
and now b3 so strengthening the c4 pawn
here
we have rook to e8 and now bishop back
to e3
the bishop can now be shifted to d4 at
any moment if needed uh we have a5
magnus grabbing more space on the queen
side and now a4 and here knight e to d7
so here magnus wants to shift the knight
over to over to c5 to put pressure uh on
b3 but also from c5 it will also be
nicely uh
defending the the de for pawn uh so g4
by duda and not knight to c5 as planned
and now the question is what do you what
do you do here a very interesting line
is uh a b4
but it doesn't really offer dude all
that much for example if b4 we're going
to capture the knight here and after c
captures we're gonna capture and be four
pawn captures and now the knight will
simply move uh and uh just you know be
shifted over to f6 if a if a5 we just
play this and black has sufficient
control of the b6 square
not a problem and the white doesn't
really have anything here so duda uh
doesn't uh just push uh he plays rook to
b1 uh and now magnus captures on d5 we
have knight captures on d5 c captures
and now f5 uh with the idea of well
busting open the position here he wants
to go after the white king uh but it
doesn't really do you any good because
queen f6 is coming rookie f5 is coming
and you're not going to be able to to
keep the spawn
so instead we have queen to d2 by duda
now maybe with ideas of pushing g5 here
but now we have rook to e5 by magnus
so what do you uh what do you do here
well uh if if you tried g5 now then you
just lose the d5 point there's really no
point in that so do the defense that we
have c4 uh and now queen the h4 by
magnus and now there are a lot of pieces
here around uh the black king this pawn
is very nasty it can be pushed to f4 you
can capture on g4 this rook is coming to
f8 and uh duda needs to figure out what
to do with the king one interesting idea
is maybe king the one king to c2 and
just try and hide the king on the queen
side
but duda plays bishop to f4 he attacks
the rook rook the e7 and now king to f1
and it's uh it's an interesting decision
they're going to the king side here
because there are so many pieces
surrounding the the white king here and
magnus brings another one rook to f8
we have g5 by duda trying to open up a
black's king side but there is a move
that really just uh
makes
life very very difficult for white here
so this is the first positive video
moment pause the video and try to find
this idea for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
elusive idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to e3 that's the good stuff not only
does it attack the bishop here because
the queen no longer defends the bishop
but it also frees up the e4 square for
our knight and that's that's the point
so what can you do here yeah if you
capture with the f pawn then we play h
captures on g5 and then these two pawns
are just too strong bishop moves we're
going to play f4 and now the rook
is on f8 we're going to open up the
position and it's a game over for white
so duda of course captures the pawn we
have bishop captures on e3 with the
bishop
and now knight the e4 by magnus and
again uh what do you do here the queen
is attacked the f2 pawn is also a kind
of attack and if you if you trade here
uh just bishop captures we're going to
play queen captures on e4 and now
there's a an attack on both rooks here
so you're gonna have to give up one of
them uh so instead we have queen to d3
and now comes f4 so challenging the
bishop here and now if you capture an e4
which seems like it's possible just f
captures on e3 and it's game over the f2
pawn is now attacked three times and
also the bishop here is attacked twice
there's nothing white can do here so
after f4 we have bishop to d4 by duda
and now knight captures on g5 the knight
is attacked so we simply capture here
and we prepare to further push probably
with f3 so duda prevents this by pushing
f3 but now look at this lonely bishop
here it's it's basically a pawn and it's
very difficult to really even imagine
how this bishop or rook will ever see
the light of day or this rook you know
uh for that matter uh and now what does
magnus do well he simply brings the only
inactive piece into the game it's his
light square bishop on b7 and he now
shifts this into the game with bishop
the c8 and now the h3 pawn is attacked
three times and the white can't really
add any more defenders so here we have
queen to d2 uh now preparing queen to e1
to try and trade off the queens and the
magnus simply captures it knight
captures on h3 uh we have queen to e1
and now magnus could play queen h5 for
example and keep the queens on the board
his position is well much much better
this row can come to the e8 you're going
to put additional pressure here but he
is already up one point in the match if
he gets a draw here then duda will not
be able to win the match uh even if he
wins the final game so he simply trades
queens we have queen captures king
captures and now knight the g5 and here
magnus is up upon but his position is uh
much better there's uh well there's no
easy way to activate this bishop so here
we have rook to h4 he's going to try and
organize an attack on this pawn here and
maybe bishop to c3 rook to d1 bring the
rook here and add another attacker maybe
bishop to d2 attack the pawn from there
so maybe something in those lines so
bishop to f5 by magnus attacking the
rook on b1 and the duda just lifts it
with rook to b2 and now the c5 pawn is
hanging so magnus brings the bishop back
and now king to f2 we have rook e to f7
now adding more defense here and white
really doesn't have any choices here
it's uh
it's a position where you might be able
to survive but duda needs a win here so
rook to d2 he's going to try and
organize an attack against this this f4
pawn
and now rook to e8 by magnus we have
bishop to f1 uh but not knight to h7
uh we have bishop to c3 uh like i said
where he is trying to attack this pawn
but it doesn't matter knight f8 and the
knight is now coming to g6 with tempo
it's going to attack the rook and also
add more defense to the f4 pawn so rook
to d4 but now just knight to g6 so now
the rook has to go back uh we have
rooked h1
and now king to h7 so there's no way to
make any progress here and the rook is
well has a firm grip on the e3 square
with the pawn uh you can't really push
this pawn it's just very very difficult
to even look at this so bishop to d2
adding another attacker but now rook e
to f8 magnus says i'm very happy with my
position here you're gonna have to try
something so bishop to g2 and now knight
to e5 and now magnus has some ideas of
g5 g4 and well it's going to be very
good for him the knight controls g4
bishop controls g4
and the white can only wait and see what
happens so here we have rook back to a1
uh he wants to play b4 and then maybe a5
and try and open up the position on the
queen side just to gain some activity
magnus continues with his plan on the
king side we have g5 before now captures
captures and now uh rook to a8 in
expecting a5 so duda still plays it he
he has no other moves basically we have
b captures on a5 uh although here c5 is
also just playable it's uh it's very
interesting why magnus decided against
this maybe it's just uh
a move that you kind of miss but here
for example this captures uh d captures
on c6 knight captures still attacks uh
both the uh the rook and the bishop and
it doesn't seem like there's a good way
to play this rook captures here we're
gonna capture on b4 and
that's just it okay you can capture
maybe on b6 have this past pawn here but
it's still okay two best pawns for a
piece uh might be playable but but it's
it's not enough to to to to actually do
something with this but it's a rapid
game so no point in giving him any any
chances magnus captures on a5 we have
rook captures on a5 rook captures bishop
captures and now
we have c5 the c7 pawn is attacked so
you could just move the bishop and let
the rook defend the pawn but magnus
plays c5 he wants to get rid of any
pawns here in the center of the board
and then he will just be up a pawn so d
captures on c6 alpha knight captures
attacking the rook we have rook to d5 as
the knight also attacks the bishop so
bishop to e6 now forcing this trade and
now duda doesn't really have a choice
rook captures on d6 knight captures on
a5 rook captures on e6 and knight
captures on c4 and this is the resulting
end game uh rook and
knight against rook and bishop where
magnus is up upon so there is no uh
real chance for duda here other than if
magnus just blunders something so bishop
to h3
activating the bishop now comes knight
to e3 keeping an eye on that g4 square
so now we are even planning is something
like maybe h5 g4 in the future so bishop
to g4 keeping an eye on the h5 square
and now rook to a7 and now the problem
is uh you could uh maybe hold this with
uh just repeating with bishop to h3
because by playing rook to a seven
magnus is trying to get rook to a1 rook
to f1 checkmate
so maybe just bishop to h3 and wait and
see what black will do and then we will
see some like h5 rookie five attacks the
pawn king g6 defense maybe rookie six
check king has to go back rookie five
again and then probably g4 uh but the
resulting end game will not be enough to
for black to win this for example
captures we're going to capture rook g5
check king to f6 and now we're going to
give up the rook here for the pawn and
knight captures captures and captures
and now you get this end game where
magnus is up the exchange but the bishop
and pawn are
on light squares and you can just you
know keep an eye on this pawn with
something like this uh maybe this is a
table base win but i don't think it is
i'm pretty sure it's a draw
but duda needs a win so he tries king to
e1 but this runs into trouble magnus
plays rook to a1 with check king to d2
and now knight captures on g4 so now the
g4 pawn will fall as well f captures and
rook to g1 there is no way to defend
this spawn king to d3 and magnus grabs
another pawn so now he's up two pawns
but at least duda avoided a draw he's
still hoping for for something uh king
to e4 we have rooked the g3 now
preparing rook to e3 check the well pick
up the the rook here so king f5 and
still rook to e3 the resulting end game
will be of course winning for magnus so
rook to a6 and now rook captures an e2
and now
again it's completely lost but the duda
has to try king f6 maybe he somehow
checkmates the black king uh we have
rooked the e8 by magnus and now rook to
a7 check king the g8 rook the g7 with
check king h8 and now rook to f7 but now
rook the g8 and magnus is now ready to
start pushing his past pawns with king
f5 but now king
sorry not king but now g4 and it doesn't
matter if you capture this pawn we're
just going to continue pushing g3
there's no way to stop the pawn
so duda instead goes rook to f6 tries to
get this rook captures an h6 in but now
g3 he doesn't care about this pawn so
rook captures with check king g7 and now
rook to h1 magnus continues with the g2
everything with tempo so you can even
play f3 next to defend your pass pawn
rook to g1 now comes f3 and there's no
good good defense here we have king f4
and now okay you can't push it because
this comes with check and then you lose
both pawns but we have rook to f8 to
check king to e3 and now king to g6 uh
we have king to f2 by doodah now comes
king to g5 and now
would you play do that right rook to a1
but now king to g4 we have rook the a7
now rook the h8 uh rook to g7 with check
now comes king h3 and here king to g1 so
stopping the king from reaching the h2
square but the problem is there is only
one move that wins here for magnus so
feel free to pause the video for the
second time and try to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not doing anything
weird like for example moving the the
rook somewhere and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is f2
with check we have to sacrifice this
pawn and then the game is over
but uh to show you why this is so we're
first gonna try something like rook to
a8 to deliver rook to a1 check and try
and win the game this way the problem is
there's rook to g3 check if we
just sacrifice the rook like this then
we get a stalemate okay magnus still
wins the match but he doesn't win the
game
and if you try running away with the
king then we play rook captures on f3
and that's it we have in sufficient
resources to draw this game uh so the
only move that winning that wins the
game is the one that all of you found
that's f2 with check we sacrifice a pawn
king captures on f2 and now rook to f8
to check again the only move uh if you
try something like king h2 of course
rook captures and g2 just wins the pawn
so this is crucial rook to f8 to check
now king the g1 loses to rook f1
checkmate so the king has to move but
after rook to f8 to check it was in this
position on move 76 that young [ __ ] of
duda resigned the game and magnus
carlson wins the entire match so same as
yesterday first game ended by magnus
winning then draw then magnus one and
today it was exactly the same first game
win second draw magnus wins the third
but only with the black pieces so magnus
won both games with the black pieces and
here you resign because if you move the
king then comes rook to f1 with check
king to e2 and now just g1 queen this is
how we win this end game so captures
captures and of course it's a very
simple from from here on out
uh so yeah once again now after rook to
f8 to check he resigned and a very nice
victory for for magnus uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
we're gonna show other games from the
match uh uh levon and mamiyarov had uh
some very nice uh nice games as well and
the other pairs also uh and the winner
of this match uh uh who is magnus will
face the winner of the match uh
mamidarov
that we will also check out uh so yeah
uh stay tuned for that uh i would like
to thank seth hanson jessica ricovicious
uh hayden queenie uh aditya parasarat
parasarati and christoph alexander soppa
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this very nice event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day